we're gonna talk about frogs that's for
hate yeah so yeah are you okay so yeah
when we saw I mean when I saw the video
that you put up was it two days ago now
yeah yeah two days ago I couldn't
believe it yeah and the next morning I
got an email from my brother who also
studies symbolism and it's very a very
smart person and he he said this Jordan
oh he's incarnating Pepe right now
yeah well the funny thing is you know I
knew about Pepe but what it was I had
nothing like that on my mind when I made
the video it never even entered my mind
that that was an association I mean I
was just concentrating on this Kermit
thing that had popped up had probably
popped up about two years ago and I the
first time someone said that I thought
huh so I went listen to Kermit and I
thought oh yeah I do have a voice that
similar to that I see I can get it lower
but my voice tends to rise up into my
right into my it's because of tension so
so this is it we need to do it like so
we need to do the metaphysics of Pippin
no one has done it yet I think yes
exactly so you know and then then this
strange occurrence of course also also
emerged with regards to the mask that
Charles had made me or the hat yeah
which looks like poppy I know it even
has red lips yes staggering it's
absolutely staggering and so I just
about fainted when I posted that and
people start people pointed out the
correspondence with Pepe really I just
about fainted it was and that doesn't
happen very often like I can only
remember one other time in my life when
I was shocked enough to almost faint I
just thought that was just too much it
was too much to bear and then thinking
about the Frog correspondences since
then it has been well it's it's it's
it's it's inexplicable and absurd but so
much of this is inexplicable news early
I don't know I we did something
yesterday I looked up maps of meaning my
book on on the Amazon seller lists to
see where it was located and it was
number eight on
on books that are associated with
behaviorism yeah and we and it was
bracketed by two other books Mazarin
Banerjee's book and she's the person who
invented the IAT
that's been used to ferret out
unconscious bias oh my good and the
other one was a book by Richard Bandler
that I think was called frogs and
princesses just and then to find out
about cat cut you know I I didn't know
about Karen anyways it's and then today
I was thinking I was watching Nina Paley
who was a absolute genius and she's
animated the the plagues that that Moses
called down on the Pharaoh and of course
one of the plagues was a plague of frogs
yeah and so okay so the Frog the Frog is
is is a is a perfect liminal character
because the Frog I think you tweeted
about this as well the Frog lives both
in water and on land and so it's like a
it has a monstrous characteristic that
it can cross oh it's at one of those
things that crosses over between between
worlds and so you see that you see that
in the stories like the story of the of
the the frog in the princess is a
perfect example and it relates to the
Pinocchio story that we talked about
earlier so a princess goes to a pond
she's playing with her favorite thing
which is this golden ball and so she
drops the ball and you know that that
just to mention something that golden
ball is the same thing as the snitch
that Harry Potter chases in in the
Quidditch Games in Harry Potter and it's
funny because inside the snitch is
actually part of Voldemort's soul right
so and so that's part of the soul of
evil that's inside the golden ball and
the golden ball and Harry Potter has
wings which makes it around chaos
technically speaking it's an alchemical
symbol and the round chaos is a
mercurial symbol and the spirit mercury
is an emissary of the gods and so the
gods are speaking to you and then when
anything flickers in front of you and
captures your attention
mm-hmm and in the Quidditch game the
person who follows what captures his
attention is the seeker and also the
person who wins not so much the game but
the metagame what's important I think in
this story is that the ball is the most
important thing so
her it's the idea that it is the most
important thing so she drops this ball
in the end the water gets it gets lost
so she loses the most important thing it
falls into chaos right so there's a
death of God
yes attention purposes or just the idea
of Scour just the idea of the loss of
innocence or you know whatever whatever
you you think about it and in terms of
the loss of the most important thing and
so this frog appears and says you know I
can go get your ball if you if you if if
you promise something for me and so the
promise is that she will bring the Frog
with her into her castle let the Frog
eat with her and then let the Frog sleep
in her bed okay great we've got those
two things food and sex we talked about
before as well so she so the Frog goes
down into the water and then brings up
the most important thing and the
princess is forced to accept this frog
in her she doesn't want to be like she's
very annoyed that she has to to let the
Frog into her house eat from her plate
and then finally into her bed but by
doing that the Frog of course transforms
into a prince here you have this this
this idea that we talked about before
where the most important thing goes out
into chaos and whatever it can bring it
bring it back right whatever it can
bring it back to us has can be tamed and
can enter into into the world can very
finest places yes exactly yeah well
that's not something for people to
really think about about about marriages
for example so you know people are
always and I think this is part of the
profound immaturity of our culture
people are always running around waiting
to find the perfect person who's perfect
for them and so you know one thing you
might think is that if you ever found
the perfect person they would run away
from you screaming immediately and so
because and so that perfection is
something that you have to build within
a relationship and so you accept the
other person so to speak warts and all
and hope that they do the same to you
and swear that you won't run from each
other and then as a consequence of that
you can engage in a mutual process of
transformation that emerges as a
consequence
of telling the truth and and and having
a truthful relationship and then as a
consequence of that the transformation
can take place and you might start with
a frog but maybe you end up with a
prince so yeah so like we talked about
the idea that that this is the structure
of the world and so it happens as much
on a personal level as it does on a
social level and it may be a bigger
bigger sense so just a little hint we
talked about before the story of Abraham
and the three angels coming and
announcing the birth of of Abraham's son
well in the story of Sleeping Beauty
that's exactly what happens the Queen
goes to the pond and and they're low and
behold as of talking frog and and the
Frog is the one who announces to the
Queen that she will have a child the
most beautiful child in the world and so
again here is this idea of something
coming from chaos yeah interesting
because you know in the diagrams in in
my book and maps of meaning one of the
diagrams is an egg shape that that that
is the chaos into which things plunge
but chaos is a is an absolute state in
some sense it's it's the state of the
unknown as such and you never see the
unknown as such you always see something
that's partly known and partly unknown
and that's what the frog is sitting on
the edge of the pond the Frog enables
you so the Frog is an emissary of chaos
roughly speaking and you always only
meet an emissary of chaos you never meet
chaos because it's it's it's like a it's
like a it's a non non non it's it's
non-existence it's right on being it's
below being if you will right right
exactly and so now this thing like what
two things one is interesting is that
Kermit the Frog is is the same thing
because Kermit is is a host he's the
host on a on a show and so what he does
is he transitions
he's the transition between different
worlds so you hurry have an act and then
you have this transitional figure which
appears and then you have another act
and so right that's what that's the role
that Kermit the Frog plays on the Muppet
Show on his project yes his primary
problem is with Miss Piggy who's a
really loud feminist
that's hilarious okay and now now Pitts
because oh here's here's here's the
metaphysics of Peppe so so this is
what's happening in the world right now
is that there's a very strange situation
where the the people like let's say the
right we'll call them the right or like
the forces of order or the let's say the
norm the people who create the norm for
a society okay so we're in a situation
where things have been inverted and the
people who supposedly in the narrative
are the ones who create the norm are are
being marginalized they're being right
they're being pushed into the into the
margins right and told you're the ones
who create the norm and we're going to
push you out into into the margin and so
I think that's why they've identified
with the Frog that's why they've
identified with the rock because the
what happens is there's a strange
inversion that happens right the power
of inversion and the power of mocking
and the power of of humor is usually on
the side of of chaos it's usually on the
side of the power of the margins yeah
well I noticed like you noticed this
happening about 20 years ago is all that
the right-wing had all the comedians I
thought what the hell's going on here
the right-wing doesn't have the
comedians it's the rich the left it has
the comedians they're a ones that are
poking fun so the stories are very
strange that the comedians have become
that the right wing has started to
express itself in comedy yeah so that
it's a sign that there's that there's
this strange inversion that's happening
and so there's there's an interesting
like just a little footnote on this like
in the in the Bible there's a story that
talks about this it's the story of
Elijah so in the time of Elijah
Israel has you know been worshipping
false gods because of the Queen Jezebel
right and Elijah who is supposed to be
the prophet of the god of that of those
people has become a marginal figure and
so his name is Elijah the stranger which
is very odd because you he's not that he
is supposed to be a prophet of God and
his tool is mockery he mocks the
prophets of Baal and that's something
that you actually don't see very often
in the Bible where the tool to kind of
bring back
is through mockery and so this is what
we're seeing with this Pippo figure is
that Pepe is like it's like an inversion
machine okay so so so the people who use
Pepe what they do is they they taken
something like an insult that's being
thrown at them and they flip it around
they flip it around on those that
insulted them like that's what you did
with the Kermit thing which is perfect
you you you know you people are making
fun of you because they say you sound
like Kermit and you're saying okay I'm
gonna take this and I'm going to make it
into my strengths and that's what Pippi
Pippi does and so a lot of the crazy
stuff that's coming out of this Pepe
thing is is is is part of that there's a
lot of dark things and in the pit bay
you know like things that like purrs
that I wouldn't necessarily want to
touch yeah well I mean when I first saw
the Frog I mean the Pepe frog I really
recoiled from it it's it's got this kind
of underground comic horror associated
with it that I really I really find
distasteful
so like sort of viscerally distasteful
you know but I think it's supposed it's
a it's kind of supposed to do that to
you yeah that's part of the power of
those that are using that that image
like it's right there if you look at it
it's right there in the first comic like
the first tippet comic you know you have
a it's very crass but but here's this
this frog right who goes to the toilet
to urinate but he pulls his pants down
to his knees and so he's doing something
that usually you if you pull your pants
down to your knees you're going to sit
and do something else but then he does
that but he stands and so here's this
and he shows us his backside right so
here's this this strange power of
inversion which actually brings the man
to stand back up and so that's this
double inversion that people who use
this this this type of imagery are doing
and so even it's like you know let's say
you like the radical left when you're
saying you're you're this whatever
you're a white male controlling bla bla
bla bla bla you're all these things and
the people who use these Pepe comics
they're they say yes and they'll and
they reflect that to you and then the
people who will accuse them of that
completely lose their mind they
completely lose their mind but the only
thing they're doing is saying you're
saying let's say that I'm a racist this
blah blah blah and then they reflect
that back
them they invert it in a way because
they're saying here you go I'll show you
what you're telling me I am and then in
ten you know the left the radical Epping
lose their mind and so it's like and so
it's kind of and and if you look at
those people like the alt-right people
they have this strange this strange
magic right because look at look if you
look at my lowest my lowly innopolis is
a perfect example you know here is a
half Greek half Jewish gay Catholic
Trump supporting Englishman from
Englishman in America and and so not
talking to the Republicans exactly and
so nothing people can throw at him will
stick on him because he is the Frog like
he is that marginal figure standing on
the side but he's he's he's like he is
that double inversion and he he's kind
of I know if he's trying but what it
seems like he's doing he's bringing
order back through like it is this
double flip that's happening it's very
odd it's a very it's very strange
it's very strange so anyways I would
just say just just I mean just be
careful it's a dangerous place to stand
yeah yeah yes I'm trying to be careful
believe me I've got lots of people that
I'm talking to that are helping me
formulate my arguments and articulate
them properly and like I'm doing my best
to keep my feet on the ground and my my
eyes open and and and not to be angry
about this but to be in the chaos really
and not assume also that that's a
catastrophe because I don't know what's
gonna happen to me yeah I don't know if
this is the worst thing that ever
happened to me or the best thing that
ever happened to me
yeah I can't tell ya and when she went
the solution will happen inside the
chaos right the the the the the Jonah
gets pulled down by the whale down into
the depths of the of the of the ocean
and it's while he's in the belly of the
whale that the solution comes to him
like the various face he has he has this
moment of repentance where he turns he
turns around repentance is a flipping
around and so that the this moment that
he brings him into death turns into this
baptism where he comes out and he's you
know and he's a he's a he goes into the
city right so that's another part but
but but so that that
yeah the solution is going to come out
of this chaos yeah wow it's very problem
if it's a really complex problem you
have to go very far into chaos to find a
solution but if there's always the risk
of losing yourself when you're in chaos
all right well that's right I mean
that's the thing about dragons is that
they can eat you yeah that's that that's
why I don't like the new-age age'
fication of carl jung's thinking and in
part I think Joseph Campbell was
responsible for that although he did a
lot of very good things I mean the thing
about the thing about confronting the
thing that you're afraid of is that the
thing that you're afraid of is genuinely
terrifying and it can actually eat you
and it's eaten plenty of people before
you and so it's no joke and yeah you
know I mean during this whole let's call
it ride so far I mean what yeah what was
going to happen and especially in the
first couple of weeks I mean when I was
being called a bigot and a transphobic
all of those things and being pilloried
essentially at least within the
university for my views it wasn't
obvious at all that there was going to
be any there was gonna be any way of
swimming out of it let's say yeah sure
but it's it's very it's very disturbing
because now you have you basically have
these two monsters fighting each other
you know like like that you have let's
say this Pepe type frog and you know
that Pepe was with declared a hate hate
symbol by the the anti-defamation league
you know that I mean that's very
frightening it's frightening that this
is how far it's gone how much it's like
on you know all of a sudden they see
that they can see the monster on the
other side but they don't see the
monster on their side yeah you know and
and the LGBTQ etc etc I mean that is
itself a liminal form it's the same
thing that that happened with the
gender-neutral pronouns as soon as you
blew the binary apart there is an
endless multiplication of potential
identities now is the chaos manifesting
itself and the ever-expanding letters
that go along with LBGT there's an exact
example of exactly the same thing it's
like well
we're March sliced well we're
marginalized - well we're marginalized -
and how about us we're also marginalized
and it's like and I guess that's also
partly because each person has at least
one element of them is that seriously
margin I stand marginalized in some
manner yeah yes yeah and the right and
it's interesting like the rainbow is is
actually a perfect symbol because a
rainbow is actually is it is just a it's
it's a fluid thing it is a fluid thing a
rainbow is not six colours a rainbow is
a spectrum of colors there's an there's
it is chaos itself it's the division of
order into an indefinite amount of
things right so we we typify a rainbow
into six colours but but it's actually
just the spectrum of correct right and
so it is indefinitely it can be
separated indefinitely
great it's no limit to how much it can
be separated and it seems to me that
that's actually the problem with the
identity legislation it's like well like
imagine that like an identity is a very
important thing right an identity is
something you have but it's also
something that you and I play out so you
have to negotiate your identity with the
rest of the social world it's like a
game in some sense but a identity also
has to have a function like and this is
also why the legislation is so
pernicious because it just says well
your identity is whatever you want it to
be it's like well no it's not because
you have to live with other people it's
like it's like saying you can play
whatever game you want to play it's like
well you can't because you go play to
get people to play with that's right
we're playing together and you could say
well you have to play my game well I can
tell you toddlers on the on the school
ground who say you have to play my game
they just get shunned yeah and then a
game itself has to be playable that's
the other thing is that there there are
playable and non playable games and one
of the things that Piaget pointed out
the developmental psychologist Piaget
pointed out about a game is that one of
the hallmarks of an acceptable game is
that people want to play it voluntarily
and that's another part of the
legislation that's so pernicious it's
like okay you have a game and it's a
game that you've chosen subjectively
because that's what it says in the
legislation and when you come near me
you have to play my game
whether you want to or not yeah and then
the with the problem without - is that
well where does that stop and the answer
is it stops with indefinite
multiplication so the whole point of
society is to enforce a game that's
somewhat arbitrary that everyone can
more or less play they sacrifice parts
of themselves to play it but it beats
the total chaos of of the war against of
all against all for example that's the
Hobbesian right nightmare right and life
nasty brutish and short
this is a complement to the discussion
of the metaphysics of Pepe the Frog that
I had with dr. Jordan Peterson there are
strange transformations happening in our
world and hopefully understanding them
will prevent the worst from taking shape
as I discussed with dr. Peterson the
Frog is a type of hyper edit II as an
amphibian it exists in two worlds at the
same time so it becomes an image of the
margin another possible aspect of the
margin and the monster as we encounter
it is to be a shape-shifter shape shift
shifting like hybridity is the sign of
the place where categories fall apart on
the edge in the case of shape-shifting
this current characteristic is presented
mostly as a power of the margin it's the
power of fluidity like a trickster
taking on several forms to operate his
mischief to fully understand how Pepe
the Frog operates we need to understand
how shape-shifting occurs and how it
gives power to those who wield it you
see Pepe has become a meme possibly the
most used meme of all times his image is
floating on the Internet
and it can be produced by anyone in the
world and so there are thousands and
thousands of images of pepe ranging from
a glorified emoji to the most horrifying
scatological images you can imagine
because Pepe has become this chaotic
fluid shape-shifting thing he ends up
acting like a mirror in the same way
water acts as a mirror and the way that
works is that because there's so many
images of Pepe
when people look into that huge chaos of
images they can't encompasses all of it
they have to mentally order it and in
ordering it they do that using their own
mental patterns but is they project
their thinking into this chaos and as
they force the chaos to take shape it
becomes an image of their own ideas
maybe their own ideological possession
and so one of the things that has been
happening is that some people on the
right what what some groups are calling
the alt writer or whatever have been
using this effect to act as a mirror
against the social justice warrior types
it even went so far that the sjw's
finally declared Pepe a hate symbol the
anti-defamation league said that Pepe
was a hate symbol I mean this frog this
cartoon frog it was so ridiculous that
the ADL finally scaled back some of the
language they use I mean of course it
was politically motivated but how could
such a silly thing happen well certain
images of Pepe a few of them in the
thousands and thousands of images
available had racist themes and so there
was a Hitler Pepe and a KKK Pepe
a scheming Jew African stereotypes using
racist slurs cliche Mexicans all of
these examples were floating with the
other thousands and thousands of pepper
images online but when the social
justice warriors looked in this mirror
this pond of pepe images all they could
see were the ones that reflected back to
them their own ideology or rather like a
mirror an inversion the dark shadow of
their ideology of course immediately the
accusation came Pepe is a racist symbol
he's a hate image and the irony is very
big because first of all no one controls
this image no one has any control over
it
Pepe is everything and anything and
nothing at the same time by declaring
publicly that he's a hate symbol the
sjw's are pointing to their own
absurdity and this to the delight of
those that use this image but hiding in
this is an even larger irony if you look
at the images that they pulled out as
being racist images there's this strange
contradiction in them you see on one
side there is Hitler Pepe and KKK Pepe
and there's a Trump Pepe well on the
other side there's the scheming Jew the
african-american or the Mexican this
means that Pepe is at the same time the
archetypal oppressor seen from the side
of the victim all the while being the
archetypal scapegoat seen from the side
of the oppressor that it's Pepe is both
sides of racism at the same time when
the sjw's look at that automatically
without even thinking they organized it
through the ideology and it exposes
their program because they automatically
decide that when Pepe is Hitler or KKK
or Trump
pepé is identifying with those people
but when he's a scheming Jew or a
Mexican PIPA is mocking and criticizing
those people why is such an absurd image
of Hitler as a cartoon frog not seen as
mocking Hitler in fact all the st WS are
seeing is a reflection of themselves of
their nightmare of their shadow the
rather pathological desire we've seen in
the past few months to accuse everyone
of being Hitler or neo-nazi or a white
nationalist is an expression of their
secret desire the desire to be confirmed
through an encounter with their
projected other and it's funny because
the discourse of other nests
has been an ideological tool of the left
since the 1960s and now we're at a time
when it has come back to haunt them so
by using this strategy the people have
been wielding this Pepa image have taken
advantage of the power of chaos taken
advantage of what happens when the Frog
jumps into the pond and goes down to the
bottom to find the golden ball as I
explained in my interview with dr.
Peterson about the story of The Princess
and the Frog but the Frog can't stay in
the water forever that's the most
important thing
at some point you have to finish the
story
to finish the story the Frog has to get
the golden ball and one could say that
the golden ball is actually the Sun
which will come up for the new day the
Frog has to get the golden ball and
bring it back to the surface of the
water it must carry the most important
thing carry the seed of the new world to
the princess so that it can grow if that
doesn't happen there is no telling what
else can come out of the water if the
Frog stays there for too long it will be
eaten or it will call some darker
monster because there are other things
down there beside the golden ball and
the Frog can tempt the Leviathan to
devour it and it's not as if this is
impossible as the Frog swims in the
darkness the social justice warrior is
still peering into the mirror and
calling forth its shadow we've already
seen some intimations that this game
people are playing might raise something
more than a new day might raise the very
monster the social justice warriors hope
to encounter
so as the Frog swims in the water how
how can it do that how can it recognize
the golden ball that is at the bottom of
the pond because it's actually not easy
to distinguish things when we're covered
in darkness and the answer to this is in
what happens in the story the Frog has
to get out of the water and become a
prince the Frog has to become something
else and bringing up the golden ball is
the same thing as the transformation of
the frog into a prince
one cannot happen without the other and
so as dr. Peterson is often suggested in
his lectures the way to do it is to sort
ourselves out is to go into our own self
to find the golden ball that is hidden
in the darkness to go down and find the
most important thing of Western
civilization
and dr. peterson has suggested the most
important thing of western civilization
is the logos this truth that is the word
we have seen how noise has been the
chaos used to drown the word what i'm
gonna talk about is freedom of speech
and i want to tell you a few things
about this very carefully I've been
thinking about this very carefully over
the last two weeks
and so we must find the word for it is
the Sun that rises after darkness the
word is the thing that comes out of
death and lives again